call me dude z coattails coattails a
Burlington Coat Factory sitcom for doozy
plus starring Charlie Sheen let's take
the standard Trope of Sheen's father
owned the Burlington Coat Factory died
and left it to him David Letterman plays
the actor David Letterman yeah oh he was
great in Cabin Boy uh Charlie uh listen
I I would love uh nothing more than to
tell you all about the business but uh
I'm about to have lunch with uh Charles
Grodin and Terry Garr
are they both dead they're both they've
both passed on yes uh my good friend uh
Regis Philbin
yes Regis Philbin has passed on Jesus
Christ why don't you know this and uh I
said uh thanks Regis uh how's uh Kathy
Lee and he said uh we we haven't spoken
she's alive